foreign
[Music]
how airplanes fly
you know have you ever walked up to one
and I sound like the guy in The Matrix
you have a Marvel at an airplane that
300 tons of metal Mr Anderson no he was
talking to uh Morpheus at that Morpheus
that's right yes yeah yeah that's right
because he was talking yeah yeah he was
trying to get him to reveal the codes
the codes for uh Zion yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah so anyhow do you ever Marvel that
an airplane
of all sizes they just go fast forward
and then they fly
do you have a pause and reflect on this
I'm not gonna say I have to be honest
I'd be lying it says give me the scotch
before we take off and I'm good all
right I'll tell you what I Marvel at
right
how sometimes I get a really decent meal
in first class that to me is the modern
Aviation marble okay all right so so
here you go so you may have noticed that
all airplanes have wings yes okay
wings are a good thing that's a good
thing they also have mini Wings on the
tail okay right and then they have like
a vertical Wing uh which is like the
stabilizer wing and so that prevents it
from sort of uh fishtailing right
because if it's going quickly through
the air and air Parts on the left and
right side of that tail fin that gives
the plane stability moving in One
Direction okay now when I was a kid I
built model airplanes that flew gliders
and I tried making gliders without a
tail fin and it just fishtailed the
whole time it just didn't it couldn't
stabilize so I so doing piece by piece
adding it such attracting bits to my to
my models I was able to sort of learn
early on in my life what role these were
playing in the stability and the lift on
an airplane okay interesting yeah just
say I go back on that way back on this
no no I want to ask you a question about
gliders now but I don't want to disrupt
what we're doing oh yeah yeah okay so so
now you may have also noticed the shape
of the cross section of a wing
yes so if you take a cross section of a
wing and sometimes you can see this no
yeah you know you can see it when you're
on if you sit on the wing on the wing I
mean you're sitting in the winged seat
in the wings right so so that's usually
where the exit there's usually an exit
uh door above the wing so right step out
by the way if you ever want to change
your seat just tell them that you're not
willing to take on the exit row
responsibilities you know so they'll
they'll ask you would you like to uh are
you okay with the responsibilities I
prefer the leg room right yeah you get
leg room in for in in the exit row
because if you have to file out of the
plane that's right yeah yeah but if
they're two consecutive exit rows the
first of those two egg rows the seats
don't go back so you have to watch it
yeah because they don't want to you know
and I'm like you don't want to lean into
the other exit row right because you're
being obstruction but my thing is like
how could I ever lean into the other
exit row when you guys are always
telling me to put my seat back up and
even when it's not back up you go back
like three inches yeah right yeah
exactly oh my God we're all trapped
it's reclining
no it's stuck in that position and
they're telling me to pull it forward
and I can't yeah
are you gonna be the one per the one
dead person on the airplane while
everybody else all right so uh so the
top part is curved okay and the bottom
is uh it's typically flat okay
so you have a pocket of air that the
moving Wing is passing through
and the air wants to stay as one parcel
it wants to okay okay so as you do this
the air on top to go that bigger
distance has to travel faster
to keep up with the air on the bottom so
that when it reconnects it's the same
parcel gotcha all right
so you have forced the air to move
faster on the top than on the bottom
and fast moving air has lower pressure
and I've done this before I don't know
if who's going to be listening to this
and who's going to be watching it but so
I'm going to use my letterhead okay so
here it is I don't know if you can see
from the desk of Neil deGrasse Tyson
it's a Hayden planetarium uh American
Museum of Natural History so not that it
matters what paper you do use but I'll
get a nice long
skinny strip from that there it goes and
here it is just limp in front of me and
now I'm going to blow across it okay
here I go
there you go
I'm blowing on top of top of it but that
it it
it straightens out lifts up correct So
the faster air going on top has lower
pressure relative to the pressure of the
air on bottom so the air on bottom
presses it up pushing right it's pushing
it's pushing it up you have an entire
pair of wings doing this
an entire pair of wings and the faster
you move the bigger the pressure
difference is between the two of them
period okay so on the runway
well you're ready to take off right and
the plane accelerates
the pressure difference between the top
and the bottom is becoming greater and
greater and greater
and the plane saying I'm ready to do
this okay but you don't want to rely
only on that you want to make sure this
happens so
what by the way it continues to
accelerate through this what the pilots
do is
they they in they up the flaps on the
tail wings okay right what does that do
that creates extra pressure to push the
tail down
pivoting the nose upwards
when the nose goes upwards the upward
pressure on the wings is no longer just
this Bernoulli effect Bernoulli's the
guy who first uh decoded this phenomenon
it's not only that the wing is now
pitched upward towards the moving air
pitched upward so air is flying straight
into the wing
that's going to also add to the
Bernoulli effect and that plane is going
to pop
that's why it doesn't slowly gain
altitude that plane changes its angle to
the air and it flies
high above the ground
and there's strong reason to do that
because it also reduces the acoustic
footprint of the takeoff
the higher it can get the fastest faster
it can get the the less influence that
sound is going to have on houses and
other things that happen to be in the in
the in the runway path right so
lowering property values everywhere
everywhere and so this effect of
pitching the wing so that the moving air
just presses it upward is so effective
that you don't even need Bernoulli to
fly an airplane
um you know you can have Johnson do it
or you can also you know Smith Smith is
cool you know
you can have Ray J Johnson dude but you
don't have to call him Ray you can call
him Ray J Ray J can do it right so
that's an old-timer reference there for
people over
70.
um there's a comedian Ray Johnson do you
remember this comedian I I well he's
still on online they still okay here's
they still got him still got him still
yeah they dropped it hey Ray how are you
doing you don't have to call me Ray you
don't have to call him
so uh so the upward pressure will do
that that's why
for example if you've ever been to an
air show I highly recommend it even if
you're anti-military the air shows like
display not only military jets but
future civilian Jets but you should see
what your taxpayer money is going
towards okay if you have the occasion to
visit an air show they're big ones in
the United States
um in in outside of Paris and outside of
London uh farnborough is one so these
are major air shows but anyhow the F-16
as well as other planes the last I saw
it was the F-16 airplane
uh can fly upside down
oh yes I saw a Top Gun I saw it
how do you if this Bernoulli effect only
pushes upwards
with that orientation how the hell do
you fly upside down you just angle the
wings so that the air hitting on the
front edge of it
the urge of that is to push it upwards
rather than any other direction at all
and if you maintain that pitch of the
Wings you can sustain a lift for the
airplane you can fly it at any angle for
that but if you're not otherwise in Top
Gun or you're doing fancy things you let
Bernoulli do most of the work
look at that and there you have it so
you're good yeah just creating lift now
have you seen those little winglets at
the tip lately in the last 10 years
almost all planes
have a little wing on the wings
it's like a little it's like a little
wing hand like
um
yeah all right so they knew and learned
that air moving over the wing oh by the
way the wings get narrower as you get to
the tip right take a notice of that next
time they're very large as they attach
to the airplane and then they get
narrower that's a very important feature
for strength by the way okay the
strongest part of the wing is the
nearest part to the plane all right
that's a good fact you don't want it
breaking somewhere else all right uh so
so what you have is a a a so air not
only moves over the wing but it also
moves off the wing horizontally
and what they found is the air going off
the tip of the wing created little
turbulent Eddies gotcha at any time you
have turbulence you have a drag a
turbulent drag right and they said is
there any way
to smooth over these Eddies and so they
did this research
Under the Umbrella of one of the A's of
NASA
recite for me the NASA acronym I don't
know National Aeronautics
and Space Administration Administration
the first anas stands for Aeronautics a
big part of their budget is to study
Aeronautics they discovered that if you
put a little uptick a little up angle in
the tip of your wing right you can boost
the you can reduce the drag there by
increasing fuel efficiency thereby
enabling cargo planes to carry that much
more and that much farther look at that
overall they saved between 10 and 15
percent of all the fuel costs the world
has seen since that's been introduced
and that is huge huge yeah huge yeah I
gotta tell you that's a first of all
I look at it like great for the ecology
it's you know that same yeah yeah like
but if you if you're running an airline
you know it's just it's good for the
bottom line it's good for the bottom
line and so and you'll also notice that
that little piece of the wing if it's
done in a modern design rather than the
original Giants that just slap something
on there they like glued it on with I
don't know but uh the modern design a
chewing gum it's integrated to the shape
and the form of the wing you'll notice
that the wing continues to get narrow
to that tip right so it continues to get
narrow easing the air off of the tip so
that you don't have this turbulent Eddy
so that's that's how you have that so
now here's the thing the plane wants to
get airborne
as quickly as possible Right
so there's a speed below which it will
stall in the air and just fall out of
the sky okay if it's going faster than
that then all the upward forces are
keeping it afloat all right and like I
said less than that you will stall and
drop out of the sky so when you hit that
speed okay
which by I believe is 88 miles an hour
I'm pretty sure yeah
even if it's not that right just let it
let it be yeah 88 miles an hour so
um so there's the plane
so so you want the highest possible
airspeed
the air speed is what matters to whether
you're going to stall right
it's how fast is the air moving over
your wings
so
every plane if it has the option
is going to take off into the wind
aha
because what matters is not the speed
relative to the ground because a
Tailwind would give you high speed
relative to the ground
but once your Airborne you want to stay
there and so what matters is the speed
over your wings that the air has and so
you take that's why every airport and
aircraft carriers have at least two
runways at an angle to each other
so that when the wind direction switches
they can change which Runway you're
using so that you will always take off
into the wind
always and the two the I forgot what the
exit 45 or 30 degree angle it's not it's
not at a 90 degree angle to each other
okay
no because if you do if you do the math
and the geometry on this you want it to
be about a 30 degree angle because then
all combinations what you do is you if
you if the wind changes Direction
then you just take off in the opposite
direction of the of the all right and it
turns out many solutions are solved just
by having two runways at that angle and
that's why aircraft carriers you will
see
um just take a look at their shape but
the World War II class aircraft carriers
you could they had two angles you could
land on there right yeah yeah on it and
if you're going to land from the
direction you're coming they would turn
around the aircraft carrier so that
you're coming in Against the Wind so
they you want to take off against
someone so this makes for a great bit of
um
for someone facing adversity in life
right you say to them
that airplane achieves its greatest lift
when taking off into the highest
headwinds
and that notwithstanding you are still
screwed my friend you're still flicking
this class you take go to the remedial
class too bad you're not an airplane
don't ever be a counselor okay
coach ever
the fact that you even thought that oh
my gosh
there's some person who's I got
adversity in their life
oh well
all right so also
also
they land into the wind
okay because they want their slowest
Poss slowest possible speed relative to
the ground right and that way when they
reverse the thrust of the engines that
they don't accidentally run off the end
of the runway right so that's why planes
land and take off in the same direction
often on the same Runway that's why
and you know how they know which way the
wind's blowing they look at the wind
sock Oh I thought I was going to say you
lick your finger oh then they roll down
the window of the 747. okay there we go
that's it
maybe Lindbergh did that I don't know
right uh but you look at the wind socks
and I look at the windsock every single
time and I confirm that we are indeed
taking off uh in the direction of the
win
because it's the opposite direction the
windsock is uh is pointing right you'll
see next time you want to go against the
wind so where I guess
real simple yeah but you can reaffirm
that that that the the traffic
controllers are doing the right thing
right by by making this observation yeah
they're not just up there drunken
partying you know they actually are
paying attention they're also paying
attention
exactly also the way you should they're
not just yeah they're also looking at
your ass right so so all this is going
on on the on the runway and I got more
to talk about airports I mean I've just
there's so much going on you know why
they call it the quick thing about you
know why they call Gates you know why
they're called Gates uh uh no they used
to be literal Gates okay airports you
you go up to the gates and they'd open
the gate and then you'd walk onto the
tarmac and get on the airplane
well the president still does that when
he lands in different countries but and
small airports you would do that but I'm
just saying they were literal Gates and
then we moved them indoors and now you
have these jet ways you don't even see
when you're are you am I indoors am I
Outdoors where am I because they wanted
to they didn't they were worried
initially that you have some anxiety of
getting on an airplane and they didn't
want you to have that anxiety so if so
we're all like the horse with the
blinders on
you know so if they don't see the
traffic around them so these are
blinders so you can walk smoothly from
the waiting room into your seat on the
airplane without actually noticing
you're getting into an airplane aha
see I you know I'm surprised that they
haven't come up with the presidential
escalator to get them down from the
plane because that would you know
well just a reminder that it's a real
object that really flies and thanks to
engineering for this the people that say
I don't trust science and science
we made a 300 ton hunk of aluminum fly
at
550 miles an hour across country serving
you hot food and giving you the internet
while you sit in your comfortable chair
and at the end of that you're going to
complain that that the that the salad uh
had too much salt
that's how you know you're living in the
future but see the salad did have too
much salt I mean I wasn't just
nitpicking okay I know I might seem to
imagine but
there is a reason behind my complaints
you know you're in the future that's all
I'm saying yeah man anyway planes that
there's more to talk about one day we'll
talk about the pressure difference
between inside the cabin and outside
that's a fun thing I do experiments on
that but one day we'll do more when you
have more appetite for airplanes and
airports pick this up again I like it
all right all right there's another been
another explainer with my uh co-host
Chuck Nice Neil deGrasse Tyson here as
always
keep looking up
[Music]